KATIE OSBERG: Hi, there.
My name's Katie Osberg, And I
link global retail partnerships
for Google's new and exciting
suite of business communication
products.
Today, my colleague Sean and
I cannot be more thrilled
to share our most recent launch,
Google Business Messages.
But before we dive into
what our product is,
or even how it works, it's
helpful to understand why
this technology is so critical.
As with all great
tech evolutions,
the solution often
stems from a problem,
and ours is no different.
So, briefly, I'm
going to ask you
to put your user
hat on for a moment
and humor me as I
pose a few questions.
How many of you have
experienced at least
one or more the
following situations
over the last couple of months?
Might you have had
to rebook travel?
Perhaps you remember the feeling
of going to multiple stores
and still not finding the
product you were looking for.
Or could it be that you
were working from home,
or perhaps your
kids were completing
their e-learning course,
and suddenly your internet
went out?
In all of those
situations, users
needed to get in touch
with brands or businesses.
But because there was
an outreach spike,
these critical connections
were seemingly impossible.
Almost every business
was promoting
on either their website
or answering machine
that call volumes
were up and wait times
were exceptionally long.
Few provided alternative
means to get in touch,
and resolution-- at least in
a manner that was convenient--
say, on the user's terms--
seemed impossible.
Now, if I am the customer, when
I hear "exceptionally long wait
times," I think, great.
This is going to take forever.
And who has the time to
wait on hold anymore?
Time and attention has become
increasingly more valuable.
And while exacerbated
by the global pandemic,
this concept is not new.
Users are just simply pulled
in too many directions.
But the same can be
said for businesses now.
In addition to the
overwhelming demand
to speak to someone caused
by the global pandemic,
it's no secret that
businesses have also
been tasked with an influx
of new responsibilities.
For example, most are
instituting new health
standards to keep
employees safe,
and many are adjusting
their operational protocols
to meet new and evolving
consumption behaviors.
Absent of user demands to
diversify interaction channels,
businesses are going
to have to rethink
the way they communicate
with customers, such
that interactions
are more meaningful,
result in resolutions,
and ultimately drive
connections that count.
Now, we at Google
understand that we're
often responsible for
facilitating that connection
between a user and a brand.
And over the last
20 years, we've
worked to perfect
the art of surfacing
the right product, service, and
business in the moments that
matter.
But as technology
evolves, we've come
to understand that
surfacing a call button--
or perhaps a link to
a Contact Us page--
might not be the
most effective way
for us to facilitate
this connection.
In fact, these
connections can be
incredibly expensive
for businesses
and extremely
frustrating for users.
Did you know that businesses
spend $1.3 trillion
on 265 billion customer
service calls each year?
And 67% of people
raised their hand
indicating that they would
rather message a business
than speak with a person.
The communication
experiences of today
are expensive, frustrating,
and frankly inconvenient.
Which is why users have begun to
demand conversational messaging
solutions, not just from Google,
but from their favorite brands
and businesses.
To be successful in this space,
it has become abundantly clear
that three things must be
true about your messaging
experiences.
They must be asynchronous,
enabling users
to pick up and exit
the conversation
at their convenience.
Automated, returning responses
to users in real time.
And finally, assisted,
helping users
to determine which products or
services are right for them.
Today, as a result
of these learnings,
we couldn't be more
excited to share
how we've evolved the Google
search experience to facilitate
making connections that count.
Over to you, Sean.
SEAN FALCONER: Thanks, Katie.
My name is Sean
Falconer, and I lead
developer relations for
Google's business communication
products.
And I'm going to take you
through our conversational
solution, Business Messages.
So, what exactly is
Business Messages?
Business Messages lets
your customers message
your business directly from
your Search and Maps results.
As Katie described, many
business conversations
begin on a Google surface
like Search or Maps.
And until recently,
customers are both
calling your business
for support or digging
through your website to find the
correct means to contact you.
With Business Messages,
you can provide customers
high-quality help through
your Search and Maps results.
Instead of the customer being
redirected to your phone system
or website, they will
see a message button
where they can
begin a conversation
with your business.
So, how do you go about creating
a conversational experience
for your business with
Business Messages?
Let's take a look.
As a consumer, your
customer user journey
begins as it does today, by
searching for that business
on Google Search.
Once you find the business
you're trying to contact,
instead of only seeing Call,
Directions, and Website
buttons, business enabled with
Business Messages will also
have a Message button.
Tapping on the
message button will
launch a conversational
surface where you can begin
chatting with that business.
These conversations can begin
on an iOS or Android device.
Behind the scenes,
what is happening is
the messages sent from consumers
are passed through the Business
Messages API through
to a messaging
partner or your
business directly
via a configured webhook.
Once you receive the message,
you can pass that message
to a live or digital agent.
This diagram shows this process
in a little more detail.
The user or consumer
begins on Search or Maps,
looks up a business,
opens a conversation
with that business,
is greeted with
a customized welcome message,
and begins a conversation.
Messages from the
consumer are passed
through the northbound
API and push your webhook
as a JSON object.
The webhook parses
the received object
that contains the consumer's
message, the preferred
language of the user,
timestamp information,
a unique conversation ID, and
the consumer's display name.
Within your webhook, you
can route that message
to a digital agent as
your first line of defense
for handling common
customer support issues,
or pass the conversation
over to a live agent
to handle more
complex user journeys.
Business Messages helps you
leverage the existing user
behavior to contact your
business through Search
or Maps, where you can
continue to take advantage
of the discovery and
reach of these products,
while providing
a more direct way
for you to have real and
meaningful personalized
conversations with
your consumers.
The Business Messages
platform and API sports
which features like cards,
carousels, suggestion chips,
photos, and actions
that help you deep
link into your website or app.
By utilizing these
rich features,
you can create an
engaging user journey
to capture leads, sell products,
or solve customer support
issues.
By combining the
discovery and reach
of your business on Search,
along with the rich features I
just mentioned, and automation
through a digital agent,
you can help your consumers
solve customer issues
without the cost of a
phone call or live agent.
Like with an app or website,
the Business Messages'
rich features help
you direct the user
through a supported user journey
that can be fully automated.
Digital agents can be
created using tools
like Google Cloud's Dialogflow,
our tool for creating
agents that understand
natural language.
Companies like Walmart
have these Dialogflow
to not only power their digital
agent on Business Messages,
but also automate a large
majority of customer support
inquiries, leaving
their life agents
available to handle a more
complex and unique requests.
Business Messages
is an innovation
in creating true
customer connections.
The rich features
of the platform
help you put guardrails around
your automated experiences
so you can steer your
consumers through a happy path
to solve problems.
But aside of the
fancy features, this
is a conversational platform.
Your customer is conversing
directly with your business.
Utilizing tools
like Dialogflow help
you to automatically respond
quickly and naturally
to customers, regardless
of the time of day,
or current mode on
your live agents.
The combination of a natural
entry point from Search,
the rich user interface, and
the powerful automation provided
by tools like
Dialogflow represent
a true technological innovation.
In fact, we see
these major shifts
in how consumers interact
with technology and businesses
every 10 years or so.
Back in the '70s,
we had mainframes.
In the '80s, we had
desktop computing.
In the mid-'90s, the internet,
and then in the mid aughts,
mobile and smartphone
revolution.
It's now hard to imagine a world
today without a smartphone.
We're all walking around with
a small computer in our pocket.
This would have been
unheard of 20 years ago,
but it completely changed
how your consumers interact
with their business.
You had to adapt to creating
an app for your business,
redesigning your
website to adapt
to smartphone screen sizes.
And now, I believe the
next shift that's happening
is around AI messaging
and personalized
rich conversations.
Business Messages
is Google's solution
to help your business adapt to
this technological evolution.
All right.
Let's take a look at a
couple real world examples.
This first demo is
from Walmart, who's
live with Business
Messages for some
of their locations
in the United States.
They deployed a digital
agent for experience,
where they use Dialogflow to
create a conversational agent
that can address common
customer support issues,
like opening senior
hours, COVID-19 protocols,
and looking up store locations.
Their Business
Messages webhook is
using Node.js to call
in Dialogflow APIs
to power the digital agent.
They did a lot of
iteration on automation,
reviewing where the
original Dialogflow
agent was unable to help, and
made iterative improvements.
They're now handling the
majority of customer support
requests through
their automation.
Let's take a look
at their experience.
Let's begin our journey to speak
to my local Walmart, the Google
Search.
So, I look up Walmart
San Jose, and I'm
shown a few different
potential locations.
I choose the Walmart
Supercenter that I know,
and I see the local
listing result.
To begin my chat
experience, I tap
on Message, which opens
a conversational overlay
with this specific Walmart.
I see a customized
welcome message,
letting me know what this
chat bot can help me with.
I choose to agree to
continue my conversation.
Once the chat bot receives
my acknowledgment,
my conversation with the
digital agent begins.
From the greeting, I
can see a chip list
of the various types of user
journeys the chat bot supports.
Things like hiring, pickup
times, inventory, hours,
store safety, and so on.
There's really a lot that the
chat bot can help me with.
I'm going to choose store hours.
When I choose this
item, the request
is being sent back through
the Business Messages API
to the Walmart webhook,
and then the webhook
is sending this
request to Dialogflow
to compute a response based on
the query, and in this case,
the specific Walmart
location that I asked about.
Because this is
a chat interface,
I can also just type my request.
So I'm going to ask, do
I have to wear a mask?
Once I hit send,
the same process
to handle this message through
Walmart's digital agent
will be carried out.
And we can see that
since July 20th,
all shoppers have
to wear a mask.
This is super helpful.
I'm going to ask
one more question.
This time, I ask,
is there a limit
to how many people can
be in the store at once?
Once Walmart receives
this request,
they respond letting me know
that they are taking measures
to promote social distance.
And they include a link out to
read more about these measures.
So, with the Walmart's
Business Messages experience,
I was able to find out the
hours and the COVID-19 protocol
requirements from
my local store,
all without having to wait
to speak to a live agent
or dig through the Walmart
website for the information.
Because Walmart is leveraging
Dialogflow in this experience,
I can also have a
natural conversation
with the bot, which is
really, really amazing.
This second demo is from
Woolworths, Australia's largest
supermarket chain.
Like Walmart, they use
Dialogflow to create
a digital agent first approach.
They put a lot of their
company's personality
in the automation, following
conversational design
best practices.
So just starting
with the persona,
creating a unique voice,
and example dialogue.
Besides handling simple
questions and answers,
the agent also helps
customers look up inventory
within their local Woolworths.
Let's take a look at their demo.
As with Walmart, I begin my
Woolworths chat experience
with a Google Search for a local
location, this time in Sydney.
Directly within
the Search results,
I see the location
I'm looking for,
and I can tap on
the Message button.
I see that I am
talking to Olive,
Woolworths' virtual assistant.
And there are some
conversational starters
I can use to begin
my conversation.
I'm going to start by
trying to find a product.
Olive prompts me
for the product.
And I'm going to try to find
hand sanitizer, something
that we all likely
need right now.
Olive is looking at
the query and does
a great job of
setting expectations
about the stock levels.
My results for the specific
store come back in a carousel,
and I can see that although the
first brand is out of stock,
there is another
brand available.
And in fact, it's even
available in aisle 14.
I know my local store
has hand sanitizer.
I'm going to search for another
product by simply typing in,
I'm also looking
for Tim Tams, one
of my favorite
Australian treats.
The same process is
carried out, where
Olive is going to
understand the question
and look up the stock levels
for this specific store
and product.
Once my results are returned.
I see that there
is stock available
in a few different
flavors, and they're
available in aisle nine.
Now that I know when
I need it available,
I'm going to look up the
location's store hours
so I know when I can pick up
the hand sanitizer and Tim Tams.
Looks like most stores
are back on regular hours.
Oliver returns both
the store hours
for location I was interested
in, as well as others close by,
so that I have a few
different options.
I can also see that
there is more information
available through the
store locator, which
is an action that deep links
in the Woolworths website,
where I can get more information
about the store location.
This Woolworths Business
Messages chat bot
is live across
locations in Australia.
The real-time inventory lookup
is a powerful experience
for customers, saving us
potentially unnecessary trips
in the store.
Those are just two examples
of existing experiences
on Business Messages today.
There are many other
customer journeys
that you can potentially
create on the platform
for your business.
To talk about the
future of messaging,
I'm going to pass
this back to Katie.
Thank you very much.
KATIE OSBERG: Thank you, Sean.
It's inevitable that
users will not only
expect this technology,
but eventually
demand it from their favorite
brands and businesses.
And as this happens,
you'll start
to see a natural evolution
in the sophistication
of these conversations.
Today, these
conversations may be
limited to simplified
FAQs and the pursuit
of fast, easily
accessible information
in a streamlined format.
But they too should be
sophisticated enough
to serve as appropriate
contextual information.
Let's take a look at example.
Meet Dash, Bridgeport
Runners' virtual assistant.
In this example,
you'll see that I've
asked Dash when my store
opens in the morning,
and he promptly
returned 7:30 AM.
He also addresses my
curbside pickup and query,
and finishes by
asking if there's
anything else I need help with.
Now again, the back and
forth here is mainly
FAQ-driven, but even
within the language
Dash uses-- for
example, "it sure is,"
you feel his eagerness, which
is in line with our persona best
practices Sean
touched on earlier.
The next evolution we can expect
to see with these experiences
is consultative discussions.
This can lead to
conversational commerce,
or even assist the
decision-making.
For example, determining
which department you'll need
to be connected with before
handing off the experience
to a skilled live agent.
In the upcoming example, you'll
see that Dash has the ability
to take customer context, make
calculated recommendations,
and finally, facilitate
conversational commerce, all
within the confines
of frictionless chat.
Let's take a look.
In response to, "Anything
else I can help with?"
I let Dash know that
I'm running a 5K
and ask him for shoe
recommendations.
With his enthusiastic
attitude, Dash quickly
returns a handful of
shoes that suit my needs.
Once Dash confirms that
the product I'm looking for
is in fact available, I promptly
am deep linked to the website
to transact.
Here, you'll notice that my
store and curbside have already
been preselected, making my
checkout process infinitely
easier.
Then, within the
messaging experience,
I'm passed the appropriate
tracking information
and notified when my order
is ready to be picked up.
Pretty cool, right?
Finally, when we look to the
future of this technology,
we fully expect that come
2021, or maybe even late 2020,
marketing teams will be building
conversational strategies
into their media plans.
This is because these
conversational experiences
enable brands to build
loyalty and maintain
one-to-one relationships
with their users,
ultimately increasing
the overall lifetime
value of their
existing customer base.
Personalization will
reach new heights
as contextual information is
used to reach out to customers
in new and assistive ways.
Let's take a look.
In this final
example, you'll see
that Dash has reached back
out to me, not only to see
how my training's
been going, but also
to ensure I like my new shoes.
He then surfaces
many helpful options
including running content,
other products I may need,
as well as 5K tips.
When I click through on
the running content chip,
you'll see that I'm passed a
running techniques video that
could be incredibly useful as I
prepare for the upcoming race.
What's unique about
this experience
is that Dash didn't
ask for the sale.
He didn't even push
me any promotions.
He focused on the user and
was able to connect with me
in a way that few brands can.
As we look to the future that
is conversational marketing, ask
yourself, are you ready
for today, tomorrow,
and the future of messaging?
If your answer is yes, we'd
love to get you onboarded.
If your answer is
no, that's OK, too.
It's not too late to build
an effective strategy.
And should you have any
questions, we're here to help.
If you'd like to learn more
about Google Business Messages,
please take a look
at our website
and be sure to follow
the interest form.
From all of us on the
business communications team,
thank you for your time, and
we look forward to hearing
from you.